also Leute ihr kennt das auch bestimmt
wenn ihr viel unterwegs seid dass euer
Zimmer immer komplett unordentlich ist
und hast du nicht gesehen und ihr wisst
einfach nicht was ihr tun sollt also
erstens müsst ihr ganz simpel einfach
immer ein bisschen aufräumen das zweite
ist die Leute die in euer Zimmer
reinkommen die interessiert nur das was
sie sehen das heißt einfach die ganzen
Klamotten packen in den Schrank rein und
Tür zu dann ist alles gut und die letzte
Sache die noch ganz wichtig ist wenn ihr
keinen Bock habt auf abwaschen okay also
wirklich absolut kein Bock drauf habt
wenn ihr die Teller direkt nach dem
Essen mit der Zunge ableckt braucht ihr
sie weder abwaschen noch abtrocknen
okay